[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
c
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فقد باتت صور كصوره الزعيم الراحل ياسر
عرفات او المهندس يحيى عياش او كلمات
كشهيد او مقاومه او حماس او الجهاد باتت
كافيه لاغلاق اي حساب بحجه مخالفه معايير
النشر انحظرت يمكن فوق ال 16 مره انحذفت
حساباتي كليا يعني بعد المناشير تم تعطيل
حسابك الشخصي بشكل نهائي في عننا هي
مناشير تشييع جثمان شهيد يعني طفل تم حذف
الصفحه عشان منشور شهيد فتم يعني هي كمان
حذف الحساب عليه المنشورات اللي كتبتها
على صفحتي منشورات مثلا صوره شهيد سواء
الشهيد ياسر عرفات الشهيد احمد ياسين
الشهيد الشقاقي عندما اتحدث عن همجيه هذا
العدو الصهيوني عندما اظهر في المظاهرات
هذه المنشورات كانت هي ماده التحقيق اللي
بناء عليها تم اعتقالي
[موسيقى]
اداريا في السنوات الاخيره لجات مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وحتى المنصات الكبرى
مثل وانظم
وغيرها الى انشاء خوارزميات نظرا للتوسع
الكبير والضخم في المحتوى وتقوم هذه
الخوارزميه بالاعتماد على كلمات معينه هي
خوارزميات تشغلها وزاره الامن تعمل مقابل
خوارزميات تشغلها الفيسبوك وتتباهى وزاره
الامن باستخدامها الذكاء الاصطناعي في جمع
وتحييد المعلومات
ومواردها عندما تقوم هذه الوسائل نفسها
بتكميم الافواه ما الذي يمكن ان يقال الم
تحد عن مهمتها الاصليه فيسبوك تريد ان
تبقى على علاقه جيده مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالتاكيد لديهم الكثير من
المستخدمين اكثر من فلسطين كيف رايتم اداء
المنصات الاخرى فيما يخص المحتوى
الفلسطيني تتفاوت تتشابه ما الذي رصدت موه
منصات الاعلام الاجتماعي وسيله
الجوسسة لحصول على البيانات الخاصه باي
شخص حول العالم واضح بان هناك قرار لدى
فيسبوك وغيرها من منصات الاعلام الاجتماعي
تكميم افواه الفلسطينيين ومحاوله صد
الروايه ومنعها من الوصول الى الجمهور
[موسيقى]
الاوسع
ن